[Musique]
et sans le piano
bonsoir donc je suis très content d'être
là
parmi vous
donc je suis William mendelbom je suis
pianiste professionnel
arrangeur compositeur
besoins beaucoup de projets les sorties
huit albums maintenant j'ai écrit trois
livres
sur le pouvoir de la musique
et ce soir voilà je vais vous partager
un petit peu mon histoire
comment je suis arrivé son cheminement
comment je vois le vraiment le lien que
j'ai avec le piano qu'on a vraiment un
lien particulier
donc le piano ça a commencé quand
j'avais 5 ans
en fait on m'a mis ma mère m'a mis au
conservatoire pour prendre des cours de
classique ce qui n'a pas marché du tout
parce que voilà je suis un peu quand
j'étais petit j'étais très joué je
prenais pas trop au sérieux les choses
et c'était pas moi je me retrouvais pas
du tout dans dans ce que dans ça pendant
que le classique
donc voilà j'ai arrêté le piano c'était
un gros échec et
petit à petit voilà la vie a fait son
cours et quand j'avais 14-15 ans du coup
je suis parti en Nouvelle-Calédonie j'ai
4 ans là-bas et c'est là-bas que le
piano revient à moi
j'ai repris un piano comme ça j'ai
touché un piano j'ai joué et il s'est
passé un truc à l'intérieur de moi comme
une sorte de connexion je me retrouvais
vraiment comme si que l'âme s'éclairée
tout d'un coup et on avait l'impression
vraiment de d'être vivant et de et de se
sentir vraiment
ce moment assez magique
c'est une part de j'ai vraiment voilà
poussé le un peu le ce truc là j'ai
essayé de faire quelque chose vraiment
de de le faire un de ces moments là en
fait quelque chose d'important pour moi
donc je vais essayer de m'en rappeler
tout le temps
et voilà ça m'a beaucoup aidé aussi
socialement parce qu'en fait quand
j'étais jeune j'avais un peu difficulté
socialement avec les gens et donc le
piano la musique c'est un art qui est
assez universel c'est une langue
universelle donc ça permet de connecter
beaucoup avec les gens et voilà ça m'a
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup aidé sur ce
plan là donc sans le piano déjà
socialement je serai un peu moins social
je pense sociable je pense suite à ça du
coup je reviens à la Réunion j'habite à
la Réunion et du coup je passe mon bac
je fais une petite une licence en
économie qui s'avère un gros échec parce
que voilà encore une fois c'était pas
pour moi je me sentais vraiment comme un
besoin de toujours faire du piano me
retrouver jouer avec ça côté un peu
enfant qui est toujours resté là je
pense
et donc voilà j'ai continué
là-dessus sur cette sur
vraiment le ce lien que j'ai avec le
piano et ça m'a amené du coup à faire
une formation professionnelle et petit à
petit voilà en fermant mon métier c'est
le canal de Vincent à ma vie aussi parce
que c'est une période où je me cherchais
on a un peu perdu voilà la jeunesse et
c'est le piano qui m'a vraiment permis
de garder un chemin et vraiment de me
sentir vivant de me sentir vraiment
connecté à ce que je suis ce qui est
hyper important aujourd'hui
et donc
un petit peu après ça quand j'étais fini
mon école je me souviens vraiment à
l'improvisation donc c'est vraiment ma
force c'est l'improvisation savoir que
improviser ça ne s'improvise pas c'est
vraiment
tout ce qu'on a appris dans dans
nos vies
on a en fait pour moi je vois vraiment
ça
que c'est l'inconscient du cerveau qui
pilote quand j'improvise je sais pas ce
que je fais en fait c'est ça qui est
original qui est complètement fou je
sais pas du tout ce que je fais c'est
mon inconscient mon inconscient qui va
puiser dans tout ce que j'ai travaillé
tout ce que j'ai bossé tous les accords
que j'ai écouté depuis que je suis petit
donc ça fait une somme de pas mal de
choses et c'est ça qui va me permettre
de développer tout simplement
une improvisation sans que je sache
vraiment ce que je fais j'entends des
choses et puis ça ça se met en place et
petit à petit s'arrête jamais pour moi
c'est mathématique et philosophique
parce que la musique voilà il y a des
gammes il y a des on peut choisir des
notes qu'on improvise donc quelle note
je vais choisir quel chemin je vais
prendre
c'est en improvise pas comme ça dans
tous les sens il y a vraiment un
développement c'est très construit et
donc c'est le côté philosophique du coup
qui est important aussi donc
mathématiques et philosophique parce que
faut développer une idée donc partir
d'une mélodie peut-être ou
d'une grille d'accord et en faire
quelque chose qui a un sens et pourquoi
je le fais et quel est le BUT vraiment
parce que c'est juste pour faire de la
musique
ça c'est bien mais moi je vais essayer
d'aller au delà de ça et vraiment de
jouer la vie c'est-à-dire que jouer ce
qui vibre en moi je vais tout ce qui se
passe dans la vie et c'est vraiment ce
que je fais aujourd'hui donc voilà je
suis en improvisation et je vais
improviser quelque chose pour voir ce
qui tout simplement ce qui se passe là
parce que je ressens donc je suis un peu
il y a un peu d'émotion forcément et un
peu de peur et un peu de joie il y a
beaucoup de choses donc on va voir ce
qui sort et puis voilà
[Musique]
voilà ce qui se passe c'est à
l'intérieur de moi
et du coup
du coup on arrive un petit peu
suite à ça sur le tout ce qui est le
côté créativité
c'est très important pour moi d'être
créatif tout le temps de vraiment
vivant en fait simplement la vie c'est
quoi c'est c'est faire des choses c'est
le mouvement et pour moi voilà
c'est très important d'être créatif donc
je vais essayer de tout le temps de
chercher la créativité un peu partout
dans plein de trucs là le dernier projet
que j'ai fait en fait j'ai travaillé
avec des
chefs étoilés en cuisine gastronomique
et du coup je viens manger chez eux et
du coup je compose un morceau pour le
plat donc c'est assez original et ça me
permet de poser différemment donc
d'utiliser vraiment les goûts les odeurs
et ça bouscule un petit peu le schéma de
de création que j'ai dans d'autres
projets du coup je crée différemment je
vais ailleurs et ça m'alimente
personnellement et artistiquement et je
fais ça tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps j'essaie de
trouver une autre idée entre partir
là-bas faire notre projet ce qui me
permet
d'être en vie tout simplement
et donc voilà la créativité très
importante
façon quand on est enfant mais tous dans
ce processus là on joue on fait des
choses on dessine on a des envies
on n'est pas dans le mental et avec
l'âge voilà je sais pas ce qui se passe
mais l'adulte prend le dessus sur
l'enfant et on se retrouve un peu à ce
mentaliser en disant non ça c'est pas
pour moi ça c'est pas pour parce qu'en
fait on est une société un peu de
performance et on se dit si tu es pas le
meilleur c'est pas pour moi ça non lui
il est meilleur que moi non non en fait
ça n'a rien à voir avec ça le plus
important c'est de faire son chemin
c'est c'est un miroir face à soi-même et
on est tous différents tous une histoire
différente ce qui fait que bon moi dans
la musique j'ai plein de collègues dans
la musique c'est super on vous
complètement différemment ça n'a rien à
voir mais ça vibre et c'est ça
l'important faut que ça il se passe
quelque chose quoi c'est ça le plus
important pour moi
j'aimerais vous parler aussi donc
essentiano donc j'aurais pas j'aurais
pas été assez créatif je répète aussi
vivant je répète aussi
curieux des choses tu vas me poser des
questions
donc c'est important et j'en ai parlé un
petit peu aussi de la résilience parce
que c'est important moi je suis un
hypersensible
assez costaud costaud quoi enfin
vraiment les émotions tout le temps je
les émotions tous les jours 4 la
tristesse des questionnements
c'est quelque chose qui que je me suis
habitué et je vis avec
et du coup le piano c'est super ça
permet d'exprimer tout ça ça permet même
de d'en faire une force et devenir
prendre tout ce que je suis au fond de
moi mais force mes faiblesses et de
voilà de performer d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça je pense que que je suis
que je suis pianiste en fait c'est tout
simplement c'est c'est le côté émotif et
le côté
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière la note en
fait parce que si on sait juste pour
faire des notes tout simplement comme ça
on fait des notes et on c'est bien mais
c'est pas
c'est pas ce que ce que j'ai envie comme
je disais tout à l'heure
et du coup voilà donc résilience donc
j'ai vécu deux ans très très sombre dans
ma vie ou ça a été très compliqué
j'ai fait une déréalisation je sais pas
si ça ça parle à certains dans la salle
et en fait bon c'est un
c'est suite un gros traumatisme le
psychique du cerveau il se il se
déconnecte un petit peu et on est dans
l'état un peu bizarre avec son corps
c'est vraiment particulier
par exemple moi je le sentais plus mes
jambes j'en ai vu sentais juste jusqu'à
là mon corps mais par contre j'arrive à
bouger mon corps c'est c'est particulier
et bon j'avais ça j'avais des vertiges
ça c'était tous les tous les jours
pendant deux ans ça fait durer 700 jours
des vertiges j'avais
des fixations un peu sur tout
quand je parle à quelqu'un j'ai
l'impression d'être en dehors de mon
corps c'est super bizarre
j'avais quoi d'autre j'essaie de me
rappeler un petit peu
j'avais beaucoup de
c'était très dur de reparler avec les
gens parce qu'en fait c'est un poisson
d'être complètement taré quoi faut dire
les choses et c'est c'était vraiment
compliqué j'ai vraiment j'ai vraiment
l'impression que ça j'allais rester
comme ça tout le temps parce qu'en fait
tu fais un mois deux mois trois mois ça
n'évolue pas et ça a pris son temps et
ah c'était vraiment compliqué c'était
une période de très noir
et c'est là que le piano arrive comme
une lumière et
et ouais ça ça a été on a bouée quoi mon
pour pas couler tout simplement je vais
jouer tous les jours je composais tous
les jours j'ai enregistré à peu près 500
morceaux en deux ans j'ai fait 500
compositions en deux ans je faisais une
composition par jour à peu près c'est
simple je faisais un truc dans la
journée c'est un step by step je marche
enfin j'essaie de faire quelque chose
pour pour avancer c'était bon c'était
des trucs genre à la boulangerie juste
devant une baguette c'était un truc
énorme
à certaines périodes c'était déjà un
truc de fou par rapport à ce traumatisme
en fait et après petit à petit j'ai fait
j'ai fait mon chemin et je chaque jour
je jouais ce que j'avais fait c'était
une manière pour moi de sublimer ce qui
se passait et de me dire bon ben au
moins je refais quelque chose je vais
pas y arriver ça bon ben je vais prendre
ça et je vais en faire quelque chose et
je pense que c'est important de toujours
être résilient et de pas perdre son
pouvoir et jamais baisser les bras quoi
qu'il arrive dans la vie c'est hyper
important
donc voilà c'est c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que je fais le TEDx c'est vraiment
pour parler de ça donc le côté résilient
elle se dépasser le côté
quand on touche le fond en plus c'était
quelque chose de très particulier parce
que c'était c'était pas quelque chose
d'assez compréhensible enfin c'est
vision par quelqu'un et ça va maintenant
tu parles tu parles de ça à des gens ils
comprennent rien même toi tu sais pas ce
que c'est on te dit ça mais on sait pas
trop enfin bref il y a des gens qui s'en
remettent jamais il faut savoir moi j'ai
eu de la chance je me suis remis mais
c'est des gens qui restent comme ça
toute leur vie donc
je vous remercie le piano voilà très
important et
ben voilà tout simplement je vais
terminer par un morceau je pense
qui va un peu résumer tout ça qui
s'appelle la lueur d'espoir
et voilà que je vous remercie
je suis content d'être là et passe un
super moment
et pour résumer et sans le piano je
serai pas là je serai pas aussi créatif
la Poste sociale je serai pas aussi
en phase avec moi-même et vraiment
connecté à ce que je suis au fond de moi
et du coup j'invite tout le monde à
croire en ses projets et à ne jamais
baisser les bras et à vivre voilà
[Musique]
merci